[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JASON KU: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the 11th
lecture of 6.006,
our first lecture on
weighted shortest paths.
Until now, we've only been
talking about graphs that--
where we measure distance in
terms of the number of edges
in a path.
Today, we're going to
generalize that notion.
But I just want to go
over what we've talked
about in the last two lectures.
In the last two lectures, we've
talked about two algorithms,
breadth-first search
and depth-first search
to solve a range of problems.
Here's some of the problems
that we've been solving.
Single-source shortest paths,
where distances are measured
in number of edges in a path.
And we used BFS to
solve this problem,
starting from a
single source, usually
a vertex s that we call.
And we solve that
in linear time.
in order v plus e.
That's what we called
linear time for a graph.
For the special case of
single-source reachability,
here we had to return a shortest
path distance for every vertex.
And there was, at most, E
things reachable from a vertex.
So this is the bound we got.
But in the special case for
single-source reachability,
when our output only has
to list the vertices that
are reachable from
me, the number
of things reachable in
basically a spanning tree
of the connected
component of my source
can almost be of order E. And
so for all the little singleton
vertices in my graph,
I don't really care.
So I can get this in
order E, but that's
kind of a little optimization.
The next thing we
did was we talked
about connected components.
And we didn't just reduce
to using a search algorithm
like a single-source
reachability
algorithm like BFS or DFS.
We put a for loop around that
to explore the entire graph
by basically saying,
if I've explored
one connected
component, then I can
look at any other
vertex I haven't seen
and explore the next one.
And so that actually with some--
a little analysis,
also got linear time,
because I'm at most traversing
any component of my graph once.
That's kind of the idea.
And we can use that
using BFS or DFS really,
because we're just trying
to get a thing that searches
an entire connected component.
And then this
topological sort we did
at the end of the last lecture.
We used full DFS
to give an ordering
of the vertices in a DAG--
maybe I'll specify clearly
that this is only for a DAG--
where we have an
ordering of the vertices
so all the edges go forward
in that order, for example.
And that we also
did in linear time.
All right, in this lecture,
and in actually the next four
lectures, what
we're going to do is
instead of measuring distance
in terms of the number of edges
in a path--
so previously, distance
equaled number of edges--
we're going to
generalize that notion.
So instead counting
an edge, we're
going to count an integer
associated with that edge.
It's going to be
called a weight.
So here's an example
of a weighted graph G.
And I've labeled,
in red, weights
for each of these edges.
This is a directed
graph on eight vertices.
And I've got an integer
associated with each edge.
You'll notice, some of them
are positive, some of them
are negative.
It's OK to be zero as well.
It's just any integer
edge weight here.
So generally we're going to
be-- along with our graph
G, we're going to be given
a weight function that maps
the edges of G to, we're going
to say, integers, in this class
anyway.
In other contexts,
in mathematics,
you might have these
be real numbers.
But in this class, we're
going to deal with integers.
So each edge, if
you have an edge,
we're going to say this
is the edge weight--
the weight of this
edge e, from e.
Sometimes, if this
edge e is u, v, we
might sometimes say
the weight from u
to v, since we have a simple
graph that's unambiguous.
All right, so but this is just
talking about our notation.
So in general, for example,
the weight from vertex b
to f in this graph is what?
Can someone tell me?
AUDIENCE: Minus 4.
JASON KU: Minus 4, right?
It's right here.
And I'll be consistent
with my coloring,
because I've got
colored chalk today.
Minus 4.
Happiness.
All right, so why do we
care about adding weights
to our graph?
Well, this comes up a
lot in many applications.
For example, distances
in a road network.
if I have a road from here--
so from Mass Ave, front
of MIT, to Central Square,
we might think of
that as one road.
Maybe you've got each
road is a connection
between two intersections
in my road network.
But an edge, it takes
longer to go from,
say, Vassar Street to Amherst.
That takes a shorter
amount of time
than it does to go from
Memorial Drive across the river
to Beacon Street.
So we might want to associate
a larger distance or a weight
associated with that edge.
Latency in a
network, for example.
Maybe strength of relationships
in a social network.
And you could imagine that
it's possible maybe you're
"frenemies" with someone,
you don't like them,
and so maybe you have a
negative weight associated
with an edge in
a social network.
I'm not sure.
Maybe not.
But there are lots of
applications where you might
want weights on your edges.
So that comes to the
next question of,
how do I represent--
how do I give the
user, or the algorithm,
these weights in my graph?
We had a representation
for a graph.
Our common way to
represent a graph
was store a set data structure
on the vertices mapping
to the adjacencies
of each vertex, which
we stored in what we called an
adjacency list, which really
could be any data structure.
Commonly, it's just an
array of the adjacencies.
But you could also have that
be a set data structure,
where you can query in
constant time what--
if a particular adjacency
exists in that graph.
So there are two common
ways to store these weights.
One is just, with
every adjacency,
I'm going to store its weight.
Maybe just in a tuple.
With each adjacency, also
store weight of the edge
that it corresponds
to, just in any way.
A second way, instead of trying
to modify our graph structure
that we gave you
before, let's just
have a dictionary of all the
edges mapping to their weights.
And we already know
how to do that.
Just any set data structure--
any separate set data structure
mapping edges to their,
I guess, weights.
Bad notation, but
you get the idea.
And it doesn't really
matter how we're doing this.
The assumption that we're
going to rely on here
is that, given an edge,
given this vertex pair,
I can query what the weight of
that edge is in constant time.
And so if I'm
going to do that, I
can either store it with maybe
a hash table of hash tables--
a hash table mapping the set of
vertices to their adjacencies,
and then each adjacency
list stores its adjacencies
in a hash table.
And that way, in
constant time, I
can check what the
weight is there.
Or here, I'm just--
I could even have
just a single hash
table mapping the pair, the
edge, the tuple, constant size,
to its weight.
So either way is fine.
We're just going to
assume that we can query
an edge in constant time--
the weight of an edge
in constant time.
OK, so this is
that graph example.
It's a little busy here.
I'm probably going to erase
that in just a second.
But we're going to move on to
what giving these edges weights
implies for these problems
that we've defined
in terms of unweighted graphs.
In particular, we are
going to be concentrating
on single-source shortest
paths, again, at least
for the next three lectures.
We'll generalize that even
still in the next lecture--
I mean, in the fourth--
in three lectures from now.
But what we had here was
that the distance before
in an unweighted graph was the
number of edges in the path.
Here, we're going to generalize
that notion kind of obviously
to weighted paths.
And the weight of a path,
I'm going call it pi.
So some weight of
path pi is just
going to be the
sum of the weights
in the edges in the path.
So edge in the path, I'm
going to sum their weights.
So that's all the
weight of a path means.
It's just I'm going to sum
all the weights in a path.
So if I took a look at the--
maybe there's a
particular path here.
The path from a to b to f
to g is going to be minus 5,
minus 4, 2.
It's going to be minus
9 plus 2 is minus 7.
So just as an example.
So then what is the
shortest path then?
Well, kind of obviously
among all paths between two
vertices, it's going to be
one with the minimum weight.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: Can I use the
same edge more than once?
JASON KU: Can I use the
Right now, you're asking about
the distinction in our class
which we have between
paths and simple paths.
So here, a weighted
path doesn't really
care if we visit an
edge more than once.
So if an edge appears
more than once in pi,
we have to count that more
than once in the edge weight--
in the weight of the path.
OK, great question.
But what we're going to see
later on is shortest paths
cannot repeat an edge more
than once in certain contexts.
So we're going to get
to the problem there
a little later in this lecture.
And we're going to solve
that in tomorrow's lecture.
But if you have--
we're getting a little
ahead of ourselves.
But when we have negative
weights in a graph,
it's possible that
things go wrong.
We're going to get there
in about five lines.
OK, great.
So a shortest path--
and in this case, I'm
going to clarify that this
is the weighted shortest path--
is a minimum-- min-i-mum--
sure-- is a minimum
weight path from s to t.
Nothing too interesting
here, but there's actually
some subtleties we
have to deal with here.
We're going to call--
just like we did with
breadth-first search
when we talked about
shortest paths,
we're going to define
an expression for what
the distance or the
shortest path weight
is between two vertices.
And I'm going to
represent that by a delta.
A delta from a vertex
s to t is going to be--
let's-- I'm going to do
the wrong thing first--
the minimum over the weight
of all paths for all paths pi
from s to t.
OK, so there's a couple
things that go wrong here.
First thing that goes wrong is
the same thing that went wrong
with breadth-first search.
Anyone remember what could go
wrong with breadth-first search
for this delta definition?
AUDIENCE: Maybe there's no path.
JASON KU: Maybe
there's no path, right.
So except if no path.
Just by convention,
we're setting
delta s, t, to equal infinity.
But there's one
additional problem
with weighted shortest paths,
and it's a little subtle.
It's possible that
a finite shortest--
finite length shortest
path doesn't exist.
And what do I mean by that?
It means I could keep going
through edges in my graph
and continually
getting a shorter path.
So if the shortest-- the
minimum weight of a path from s
to t actually goes through
an infinite number of edges,
then this isn't
really well-defined.
So I'm going to change
this minimum here to--
in mathematics we would,
just to be specific,
we call it an infimum.
So if in the case where the
weight of a shortest path
can approach arbitrarily
small, then we'll
call this thing minus infinity.
So when does that occur?
When does that occur?
When could we have
our shortest path
go through lots and
lots of vertices?
Well, let's actually take a
look at this example here.
Can someone tell me
what the shortest path
is from a to actually
any vertex in this graph?
AUDIENCE: b, f, g, c.
JASON KU: Ah, OK.
So well, we could look
at this path I have to b.
Let's just take a look at b.
I have a path going from
a to b that is minus 5.
OK, that's pretty good.
That's pretty small.
And it seems that if I go around
this graph through another way,
it might be bigger.
So I go 7 plus 3
plus 8-- that's 15--
minus 1-- that's 14.
That's much bigger than minus
5, so it seems like minus 5
should be good, right?
Anyone have a problem with
this path or a problem
with this being
the shortest path?
And what your
colleague just informed
me was that there is something
interesting happening here
in this graph in particular.
We have a cycle from
b to f to g to c
that has negative
total weight back to b.
This has minus 4 plus
2 plus 1 minus 1.
So that total cycle has a
cycle weight of minus 2,
this negative weight cycle.
So if I want to get
to b, I could go there
via this minus 5 weight edge.
But every time I circled around
this cycle, I incur minus 2
to my path weight.
So I just keep going around
this cycle over and over
and over and over and
over and over again,
and I don't have any finite
length minimum weight path.
And in such cases, we just say
that delta is minus infinity.
So the problem here is that
we could have negative weight
cycles--
deserves a capital letter--
Negative weight cycles.
It's a problem.
In particular, if there
exists a path from s
to some vertex v that
goes through a vertex
on a negative
weight cycle, then I
can take that path to
that vertex, circle
around the negative weight
cycle, and then proceed to v,
and I can take that cycle
as many times as I want.
Then this delta s,v we're
going to set to minus infinity.
And in such cases, in our
shortest paths algorithm,
we don't really care about
what the shortest path is.
We're not even going to
deal with parent pointers
here, because there is no
finite length shortest path.
So I'm just going to kind of
throw up my hands in the air
and say, you know what, I can't
return you a shortest path,
but I might want to return to
you a negative weight cycle.
If you told me that this
thing has bad weight,
maybe I want you to
tell me what a path is
that goes through a negative
weight cycle to get back to s.
So that's what we're going
to talk about next lecture.
This lecture, we are not
going to talk about that.
We are going to talk about
weighted shortest paths,
though.
That's what the remainder
of this unit on graphs
is really about is
weighted shortest paths.
OK, so in weighted
shortest paths,
we actually know an
algorithm already
to solve a subset of weighted
shortest parts, namely BFS,
right?
Now, you're like
wait, Jason, BFS
doesn't solve weighted
shortest paths.
We didn't even know about
weighted graphs then.
How does that solve
weighted shortest paths?
Well, there's a
couple cases where
we might be able to reduce to
solving shortest paths using
BFS.
Can anyone think
of such a scenario?
So let's say, I mean, kind
of what we did before was we
counted the number of edges.
So if we gave a weight of 1
to every edge in my graph,
then just that graph,
that weighted graph,
corresponds to an unweighted
graph using the other distance
metric.
So in that case, BFS
just solves our problem.
And in fact, we can
generalize further.
What if all of our weights were
positive, but the same value?
If it was all positive
and the same value,
then we could just
divide by that value.
Now we have an unweighted graph
which we can run BFS, and then
multiply shortest path distances
by that value later on.
And in fact, there's one further
generalization we can make,
which is a little bit of a
tricky graph transformation
problem.
But we can also get this
linear time algorithm
for weighted single-source
shortest paths
in contexts where the
weights aren't that large.
So if I have positive
edge weights--
if I have a positive
edge weight, let's say--
using my weight color here--
that's, like,
weight of 4, that's
kind of problematic, because
I don't know how to simulate
that using an unweighted graph.
Or do I?
Anyone have an
idea of how I could
simulate an edge of weight
4 with an unweighted graph?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Have four
edges of weight 1.
JASON KU: Yeah, I can
just put four edges
of weight 1 in parallel here--
I'm sorry, in series,
the opposite of parallel.
I can just convert this
here into 1, 2, 3, 4 edges.
And if I do that for
every edge in my graph
and we have positive
edge weights,
then that
transformation can hold.
Now, that's not necessarily a
good transformation to make.
Why?
AUDIENCE: The weight
might be very big.
JASON KU: Yeah, the
weights might be very big
compared to the number of
vertices and edges in my graph.
However, if the sum of
all weights in my graph
is asymptotically
less than v plus e,
we can get a linear
time algorithm again
by reducing to BFS.
OK, so that's great.
But in general, that gives
us a linear time algorithm
in these very special cases.
And in general, it's
an open problem.
We don't know
whether we can solve
the single-source
shortest paths problem
in the weighted context for
general graphs in linear time.
We don't know how to do it.
But what we do know are some
algorithms that do pretty well.
And that's what we
use all the time.
But one more special case
we're going to go over today
is when we have this
really nice structure where
we have a DAG, a
Directed Acyclic
Graph, like we were talking
about in the last lecture.
For any set of edge weights--
remember, with BFS, we needed
to restrict our edge weights
to be positive and maybe bounded
to get this good running time?
For any set of edge weights,
if our graph structure is DAG--
it really has nothing
to do with the weights--
if the graph structure
is a DAG, then
we can actually solve this
single-source shortest paths
problem in linear time,
which is pretty awesome.
Now, for general graphs, we're
going to show you in the next
lecture how to, for any
graph-- even with cycles,
even with negative
weight cycles--
we're going to show
you how to solve
this single-source
shortest paths
problem in something like a
quadratic running time bound.
Now, this isn't the
best known, but it's
a really practical algorithm
and people use it all the time.
And we are going to
show Bellman-Ford
in the context of
the DAG algorithm
we're going to solve today.
So that's the very
general case in terms
of restrictions on our graph.
But in reality, most problems
that come up in applications
occur with graphs that
have positive edge weights.
You can think of a road network.
You've got-- or
non-negative ones anyway.
You're traveling along,
and it's not ever
useful to go back to
where you came from,
because you want to make
progress to where you're going.
So in the context where you
don't have negative weights,
you don't have this problem
where you have negative weight
cycles.
We can actually do a lot better
by exploiting that property.
And we get a bound that's
a little bit-- that looks
a little bit more like n log n.
It's pretty close to linear.
You're losing a log factor
on the number of vertices.
But it's pretty good.
This is called
Dijkstra, and we'll
get to that in two lectures.
OK, so that's the
roadmap of what
we're going to do for at
least the next three lectures.
But before we go
on to showing you
how to solve single-source
shortest paths in a DAG using
this algorithm that I'm
calling DAG relaxation here,
I'm going to go back to
a thing that we talked
about in breadth-first
search, where
in breadth-first search when we
solved single-source shortest
paths, we output two things.
We output single-source
shortest paths, these deltas,
for the other definition
of distance, the weights--
I mean, not the weights,
the distances, the shortest
distances.
But we also returned
parent pointers.
We return parent
pointers back along paths
to the source along
shortest paths.
We call this the
shortest paths tree.
So I'm going to revisit this
topic of shortest paths tree--
shortest path trees--
shortest path trees.
And in particular,
it's kind of going
to be annoying to talk about
both of these quantities--
distances and parent pointers--
as we go through all three
of these algorithms.
It's basically going
to be bookkeeping to--
distances are actually
sufficient for us
to reconstruct parent pointers
if we need them later.
So what I'm going to show
for you-- prove to you now
is that, if I give
you the shortest path
distances for the subset of
the graph reachable from s
that doesn't go through
negative weight cycles,
if I'm giving you
those distances,
I can reconstruct parent
pointers along shortest paths
in linear time for any
graph I might give you
if I give you those
shortest path distances.
OK, so that's what I'm going
to try to show to you now.
So here's the algorithm.
For weighted-- there's
the caveat here
I'm going to write down.
For weighted shortest paths,
only need parent pointers
for v with finite
shortest path distance--
only finite shortest
path distance.
We don't care about
the infinite ones
or the minus infinite
ones, just the finite ones.
OK, so here's the algorithm.
I can initialize
all Pv to equal--
sorry, oh, getting
ahead of myself.
I'm writing down DAG.
Init parent pointer data
structure to be empty.
At first, I'm not going to
sort any parent pointers.
But at the beginning, I'm
going to set the parent pointer
of the source to be none.
So that's what we kind of did
in breadth-first search as well.
Now, what I've given you is--
I'm trying to show that,
given all the shortest path
distances, I can construct
these parent pointers correctly.
So what I'm going to do is,
for each vertex u in my graph,
where my delta s of u is
finite, what am I going to do?
I'm going to say,
well, let's take a look
at all my outgoing neighbors.
This is kind of what we do
in every graph algorithm.
For each v in the adjacency,
the outgoing adjacencies of u,
if there is no parent
pointer assigned to this v,
there's the potential
that i-- u--
[CHUCKLES] I, you-- this u, this
vertex u, is the parent of v.
It's possible.
It's some incoming edge to v.
When will it be an
incoming edge to v?
If v not in P--
I haven't assigned
it a parent pointer--
and-- so this means
it could be my parent.
When is it my parent
along the shortest path?
Sure.
AUDIENCE: Sum the
distance along the edge
to the distance of the other.
JASON KU: Yeah, so we
have some edge from u
to v. It has some weight.
If I already know the
shortest path distance to u,
and I know the shortest
path distance to v,
if the shortest path
distance from s to u--
let's draw a picture here.
We've got s, we've got
some path here to u,
and we know we've
got an edge from u
to v. If this shortest path
distance plus this edge weight
is equal to the shortest
path distance from s to v,
then it better--
I mean, there may be more
than one shortest path,
but this is certainly
a shortest path,
so we can assign a
parent pointer back to u.
So let's write that
condition down.
If the shortest path
distance from s to v
equals the shortest path
distance from s to u,
and then traversing
the edge from u to v,
then exists shortest
path that uses edge u, v,
in particular this one.
So set the parent of u--
of v to u.
OK, so this is the algorithm.
I'm not going to prove to
you that this is correct.
But it kind of intuitively
makes sense, right?
If I have these
shortest path distances,
you can prove by induction
that not only does this parent
pointer point to the right place
along some shortest path here,
but it also does
so in linear time,
because I'm looping
over all the vertices
and looping over its
outgoing adjacencies once.
Same analysis as we had for
both BFS and DFS, essentially.
And then, since we can do this,
since we can compute parent
pointers from these
distances, we're
going to ignore computing these
parent pointers from now on.
We're just going to concentrate
on computing the distances,
because we're going to have
to take linear time anyway
at least.
And all these other
things take more time.
So we can compute the
distances in more time,
and then compute
the parents after.
OK, so that's what
we're going to do.
So now, with all that buildup,
let's show an algorithm.
[CHUCKLES] How do we compute
single-source shortest paths
in a DAG in linear time?
Well, a DAG-- I mean,
this is actually
a super useful, convenient
thing in algorithms in general.
DAGs are just nice things.
They're kind of
ordered in a way.
There's this
topological sort order
that we were talking
about before.
This is going to
play a key role.
There's a really nice structure
to DAGs not having cycles,
not having to deal with this
negative weight cycle problem.
You can only go in one
direction along this graph.
It's a very nice
structure to exploit.
And so we're going
to exploit it.
And here's the idea.
DAG relaxation, what
it's going to do
is it's going to start out
with some estimates of what
these distances should be.
So maintain distance estimates.
And now I'm going to
try to be careful here
about how I draw my Ds.
This is a d, this is a delta.
This is shortest paths.
This is a distance estimate.
So that's what I'm
going to be using
for the rest of this time.
So we're going to maintain these
estimates of distance d, which
are going to start at
initially infinite.
I don't know what they are.
I don't know what the
shortest paths are,
but they better be less than
infinite or else I don't care.
So that's the worst
case scenario.
It can't be worse than this--
for every vertex.
And we're going to
maintain the property that
estimates upper bound--
that should probably
be two words--
upper bound delta s, v--
we're going to maintain that
they upper-bound this thing
and gradually lower
until they're equal.
So this is the idea.
We start from an over-estimate,
an upper bound on the distance
estimate.
And then we're repeatedly
going to lower that value
as we gain more information
about the graph,
maintaining that we're always
upper-bounding the distance.
And we're going to keep
doing it, keep doing it,
keep doing it, until, as we
will try to prove to you,
these estimates reach, actually
reach down, all the way
to our shortest path distances.
So when do we
lower these things?
When do we lower these things?
We are going to lower these
distance estimates whenever
the distance
estimates violate what
we're going to call the
triangle inequality.
OK, what is the
triangle inequality?
Triangle inequality is actually
a pretty intuitive notion.
It's basically saying,
if I have three points--
thus, triangle-- maybe bigger
so I can write a letter in them.
It's basically saying that if
I have a vertex u, a vertex v,
vertex x, for example, the
shortest path distance--
the shortest path
distance delta of u, v--
that's the shortest
distance from u to v--
it can't be bigger then a
shortest path from u to v
that also goes through x.
Of my paths, I'm now
restricting the paths
I have to the ones
that go through x.
The shortest path
distance from u to v
can't be bigger than restricting
paths that go through
x and taking that
shortest distance,
getting the shortest
path distance from here
and adding it to the
shortest path distance here--
delta u, x, delta x, v.
That's just a statement of,
I'm restricting to a
subset of the paths.
I can't decrease my
minimum distance.
So this is the statement
of the triangle inequality,
that the shortest path
distance from u to v
can't be bigger than the
shortest path distance from u
to x plus the shortest
path distance from x
to v for any x in my
graph that's not u and v.
So that's the
triangle inequality.
Pretty intuitive notion, right?
Why is this useful?
OK, well, if I find--
if I find an edge in my graph,
if there's an edge u, v,
in my graph such that
this condition is violated
for the estimates that I have--
it obviously can't be violated
on my shortest path distances,
but if it violates
it on the estimates--
u, v, is bigger than u, x--
sorry, u-- how am
I going to do this?
I want this to be s.
I'm calculating shortest
path distances from s
and shortest path
distances from s
to some incoming vertex u
plus the edge weight from u
to v. All right, so
what is this doing?
I have some edge
u, v in my graph.
Basically, what I've said
is that I have some distance
estimate to u, but
going through--
making a path to v
by going through u,
and then the edge
from u to v is better
than my current estimate,
my shortest path
estimate to v.
That's bad, right?
That's violating the
triangle inequality.
These cannot be
the right weights.
These cannot be the
right distances.
So how we're going
to do that is lower--
this is what we said, repeatedly
lower these distance estimates.
I'm going to lower this guy
down to equal this thing.
In a sense, this
constraint was violated.
But now we're relaxing
that constraint
so that this is no
longer violated.
So relax is a little
weird word here.
We're using it for
historical reasons.
But that's what we mean
by when we say relax.
This thing is a
violated constraint.
It's got some pressure
to be resolved.
And so what we're doing
is, to resolve it,
we're just setting
this guy equal to this,
so it at least resolves,
locally, that constraint.
Now, it may violate the triangle
inequality other places now
that we've done this change.
But at least this constraint
is now relaxed and satisfied.
OK, so relax edge by lowering
d of s, v, to this thing.
That's what we're going to
mean by relaxing an edge.
And relaxing an edge
is what I'll call safe.
It's safe to do.
What do I mean by
relaxation is safe?
It means that as I am computing
these shortest path distances,
I'm going to maintain this
property that each one of these
estimates-- sorry,
these estimates here--
has the property
that it's either
infinite or it is the
weight of some path to v. So
that's the thing the--
relaxation is safe.
OK, so each distance
estimate, s, v,
is weight of some path
from s to v or infinite.
And this is a pretty
easy thing to prove.
If I had the
invariant that these
were all weights
of shortest paths,
let's try to relax an edge.
And we need to show that
this property is maintained.
Relax edge u, v, OK?
Now, if I relax edge
u, v, what do I do?
I set this thing--
or, sorry, I set this thing,
my shortest path distance
to v, to be this
thing plus this thing.
There's a weight of
an edge from u to v.
Now, by my assumption
that we're maintaining
that this is the weight
of some path in my graph,
if this thing is
bigger, I'm setting it
to the weight of some
path on my graph to u,
plus an edge from u to v,
and so this checks out.
So assign d of s, v,
to weight of some path.
I'm not going to write down
all the argument that I just
had here.
But basically, since
this distance estimate
was by supposition before the
weight of some path to v--
to u, then this is, again,
the weight of some path to v.
OK, great.
So now we're ready to actually
go through this algorithm.
So DAG relaxation,
from over there,
initializes all of our distance
estimates to equal infinity,
just like we did in BFS.
Then, set my distance
estimate to myself to be 0.
Now, it's possible that
this might be minus infinity
or negative at some point.
But right now, I'm
just setting it to 0.
And either way, 0 is going to
upper-bound the distance to s.
So in particular,
at initialization,
anything not reachable
from s is set correctly.
And s itself is set as an upper
bound to the shortest path
distance.
Now we're going to process each
vertex u in a topological sort
order.
So remember, our input to
DAG relaxation is a DAG.
So this thing has a
topological sort order.
We're going to process these
vertices in that order.
You can imagine we're
starting at the top,
and all my vertices are--
all my edges are
pointed away from me.
And I'm just
processing each vertex
down this topological sort line.
And then for each
of these vertices,
what am I going to do?
I'm going to look at all
the outgoing neighbors.
And if the triangle
inequality is violated,
I'm going to relax that edge.
The algorithm is
as simple as that.
For each outgoing
neighbor of v--
sorry, of u--
I always get u and
v mixed up here.
If my shortest
path estimate to v
violates the triangle
inequality for an edge,
for an incoming edge,
then I'm going to set--
relax u, v, i.e.
set d, s,v, equal to
d, s,u, plus w, u,v.
So that's the algorithm.
So if I were to take a look at
this example graph over here,
maybe a is my start vertex.
I initialize it to--
AUDIENCE: DAG.
JASON KU: This is not a DAG.
Thank you.
Let's make it a DAG.
I claim to you
now this is a DAG.
In particular, a
topological sort order
is when there's a path
through all the vertices,
then there's a unique
topological sort order--
a, b, e, f, g, h, d, c.
This is a topological order.
You can check all the edges.
So I'm going to start
by setting the--
actually, let's use e.
Let's use shortest paths from e.
Why not?
Shortest paths from e.
Vertex a actually comes before
e in the topological order.
So it has no--
I mean, its shortest path
distance, when I initialize,
I'm going to
initialize this to 0.
I'm going to initialize this to
infinite, infinite, infinite,
infinite, all these
things to infinite.
These are my estimates.
These are not quite the
shortest paths yet--
distances.
But when I get here,
clearly I can't be--
distance to me being
infinite can never
violate the triangle inequality
with something infinite
or finite.
It doesn't matter, right?
So I don't do anything to a.
Anything before my source
vertex in the topological order
can't be visited,
because it's before
in the topological order.
That's kind of the point.
There's no path from
my source vertex
to anything before it in
the topological order.
So same with b.
b is before a in the
topological order.
Now, I'm at e, and it's possible
we are violating triangle
inequality, in particular here.
I think the shortest path
distance to f is infinite.
But actually, if I go to e
through this edge with a weight
3, I know that this is
violating triangle inequality.
So actually, this
thing is wrong,
and I can set it equal to 3.
Now, that might not be the
shortest path distance.
But right now it's a better
estimate, so we've set it.
Now, I'm moving on.
I'm done with this guy.
I move to the next vertex
in my topological order.
And again, I relax
edges out of f.
OK, so here, looking
at 8, 3 plus 8
is better than infinite, so
we'll say that that's 11.
And 3 plus 2 is better
than infinite, so that's 5.
Now, I keep going
in the topological
order. g is the next.
5 plus 1 is 6.
OK, so we found a
better estimate here.
So this 11 is not as good.
6 is better, so we replace it.
Here, we haven't visited before.
It's still infinite.
So 5 plus minus 2 is 3.
This is the next in
the topological order.
3 plus 9 is bigger than 6,
so that's not a shorter path.
3 plus 4 is certainly
smaller than infinite,
so set that equal to 7.
Then, 7 plus 5 is
also bigger than 6.
And actually, you can confirm
that these are all the shortest
path distances from e.
So this algorithm seems to work.
Does it actually work?
Let's take a look.
The claim to you is that
at the end of relaxation,
this algorithm, we've set--
claim at end, all the estimates
equal shortest path distances.
The basic idea here
is that if I take
the k-th vertex in
the topological order,
assuming that these
distances are all
equal for the ones before
me in the topological order,
I can prove by induction.
We can consider a shortest path
from s to v, the k-th vertex,
and look at the vertex preceding
me along the shortest path.
That vertex better be before
me in the topological order
or we're not a DAG.
And we've already set its
shortest path distance
to be equal to the correct
thing by induction.
So then when we processed u--
s to u to v--
when we processed
u in DAG relaxation
here, processed the
vertex and looked at all
its outgoing
adjacencies, we would
have relaxed this edge to be no
greater than that shortest path
distance.
So this is correct.
You can also think of
it as the DAG relaxation
algorithm for each vertex looks
all at its incoming neighbors,
assuming that their
shortest path distances are
computed correctly already.
Any shortest path
distance to me needs
to be composed of a shortest
path distance to one
of my incoming neighbors
through an edge to me,
so I can just check all of them.
That's what DAG relaxation does.
And again, we're looping
over every vertex
and looking at its adjacencies
doing constant work.
This, again, takes linear time.
OK, so that's shortest
paths and a DAG.
Next time, we'll look
at, for general graphs,
how we can use kind of the
same technique in an algorithm
we call Bellman-Ford.
OK, that's it for today.